seguramente sabes cómo se define la
multiplicación de dos números por
ejemplo 2 y 3 y lo hacemos a partir de
la suma que cuando tenemos 2 enteros
como estos que se están multiplicando lo
que decimos es que dos por tres es igual
a sumar este dos tres veces que hay dos
por tres es igual a dos más dos más dos
ok
estamos sumando al dos tres veces y ésta
una vez dos veces tres veces y que es lo
que nos queda pues dos más dos es cuatro
más dos es seis
y entonces dos por tres en seis y para
que hice yo todo esto de recordar cómo
se define la multiplicación a partir de
la suma
pues porque vamos a definir a los
exponentes
en tes y exponentes
tal vez suena un poquito exótico pero
con unos cuantos ejemplos vamos a ver
qué es súper sencillo podemos empezar
por ver por ejemplo 2 elevado a la
tercera potencia que este es el
exponente y lo que esto significa es que
vamos a tomar el 2 y lo vamos a
multiplicar tres veces que vamos a poner
por aquí 2
ahora vamos a derrotar el por por un
puntito dos por dos
ok estamos tomando el 2 y lo estamos
multiplicando 3 veces y lo que nos queda
es dos por dos es cuatro por 238
8 entonces 2 elevado a la tercera
potencia es igual a 8 muy bien yo digo
que veamos otro ejemplo que ya ver qué
te parece si ahora vemos 3 elevado a la
segunda potencia pues eso es igual a
tomar nuestro 3 y multiplicarlo dos
veces ok
1 y 2 entonces nos queda 3 por 3 y eso
es igual a 9 aunque entonces estuvo
súper fácil esto de encontrar 3 elevado
a la segunda potencia entonces
simplemente 3 por 3
aunque ya esto también le llamamos 3 al
cuadrado ya esto a veces también le
llamamos 2 al cubo pero bueno sigamos
con esto de los ejemplos
ahora pues yo digo que hagamos algo un
poquito más complicado como por ejemplo
tomar 5 y elevarlo a la cuarta potencia
ahorita te recomiendo que lo pongas una
pausa el vídeo y trates de averiguar por
tus medios cuanto vale 5 elevado a la
cuarta potencia y cuando termines le
puedes poner play y ver la respuesta
y eso es igual a tomar 45 y
multiplicarlos o sea 5 por 5 por 5 por 5
ya verá cuánto será igual 5 elevado a la
cuarta potencia pues 5 por 5 es 25 y
luego 25 por 5 es 125 y finalmente 125
por 5 no me vas a creer pero puedes
hacer las cuentas y eso es igual a 620